you know it's up guys it's Marcus brown
line here from mkbhd and I got another
update video this is update 2.3 if I
stop hitting my microphone here this is
update 2.3 and I got some information
for you guys as there's going to be a
short pause in my videos that are coming
out this and this coming week first part
is that you may have noticed um I'm not
actually using an HD camera I did a
tutorial on how to produce any video
that you take in HD and I'm actually
using this camera right here on its mini
tripod to do my tutorials for the moment
I have recorded several unboxing videos
for you guys and still have tutorials
coming and reviews coming so there's
like a mix of tech videos coming so
don't don't leave but basically the
point of this update video is to let you
guys know I will be away Friday Saturday
and Sunday for a trip slash tournament
you may have no clue or you may know
exactly what I'm talking about
but if you're following me on Twitter
you know exactly what I'm talking about
speaking of Twitter follow me yeah cause
if you're following me on Twitter you
basically get all the exclusive updates
I will be away Friday Saturday and
Sunday which means no tutorials no
unboxing review videos they won't be
uploaded so if you have some new
products if you're watching this now I
will probably have them up Monday
Tuesday Wednesday the next week
have them coming out free guest so stay
tuned I'm not dead I'm still on YouTube
and I will be coming back to you guys
with a lot more videos I'm really
excited I've gotten almost I think I
just reached 900 subscribers a couple of
days ago or two days ago which makes me
really really happy so this video is
going to be obviously to let each and
every one of you know thank you so very
much for subscribing and people thought
I was crazy when I said I wanted to get
to a thousand subscribers by summer well
it might actually happen who knows who
have been asking me about the Sony Vegas
intro tutorial which I have said a few
times but I just want to get this out
there one more time I tried to make this
video several times under 10 minutes and
or under one gig I got the under 1 gig
card down with that compression tutorial
I showed you guys but the under 10
minutes part not at all there's about 18
19 minutes long the the shortest amount
of time I was about to make it or I was
able to make it so if you guys want to
see that intro tutorial if you guys like
my intro make sure you if you helped if
you help me get a youtube partnership I
promise that I would apply when I got to
a thousand subscribe
i bruise or by summer whichever came
first um so yeah I promise you guys I
will apply when I get to a thousand so
if you help me get to a thousand you're
helping yourself get that intro tutorial
a lot faster than it normally would have
been but that's basically it for this
update video so again update 2.3 to
catch up on all my latest updates go to
my channel page and search under the
videos update and you should be able to
find all the updates I've put out
recently of course for more frequent but
less planned out updates you could say
you could follow me on Twitter
twitter.com slash mkbhd that's mkbhd
if you want to follow me I have tons of
updates coming out maybe maybe once or
twice a day I'll definitely tell you
guys what I'm up to where I am what
videos I'm planning next there's a few
companies who are actually on Twitter
who are interested in exactly what I'm
doing so you'll be able to get the
latest updates right there either way
this has been Marcus Brownlee here from
mkbhd with a not so HD video but that's
okay because this isn't a hardware
software tutorial or unboxing or review
or anything like that anyway thanks for
watching this video I hope you like the
new mic quality I am very very pleased
with it so far I think I've got the
settings pretty much down packed for the
tutorial videos and on that's basically
it so thanks for subscribing thanks for
watching thanks for commenting and
rating it all really means a lot I love
the honors guys I love when I get honors
for the science and tech category it
really means a lot so again thanks for
subscribing and thanks for checking out
my youtube channel I'll leave this
featured on my channel so you guys will
be reminded I guess to as to what I'm up
to so thanks for watching and see you on
Monday these